[Applaudissements]
bonjour catherine bonjour alors l'idée
que l'annoncé qu'est ce que c'est c'est
de la poudre
qu'est-ce que celle qu'a trident de mona
selon catherine il s'appelle catherine
avec la spin 4 4 alors vous sortez de
céder alors je vais me trouver à côté
parce que vous êtes tous un peu dans le
même dans le même muda je vais expliquer
pourquoi après dont vous sortez deux cd
il ya un qui s'appelle des créatures
l'autre qui s'appelle l'homme à trois
mains celui qu'on va entendre après
c'est ça
m
vachement bien choisir ses biens par
michel foucault le 11 décembre sachant
bien alors catherine vous n'êtes ni dans
le bocage vendéen
c'est vrai un petit village s'appelle
chantonnay je reçois des gens des petits
villages janvier philippe ménard de
barsac philippe katerine de chanteuse a
dépassé la vie d'avant c'est journal as
et même but guy lux et là ces gens n'ont
alors vous êtes d'une famille catholique
d'une enfance mystique un philippe bon
catholique en tout 40 ans voulait être
prêtre
oui d'être fasciné par les icônes on dit
juste oui oui parce qu'on est pressé ce
oui oui ceci explique peut être le style
un peu naïf un peut nier un peu les
rythmes un peu bébête de vos chansons
oui voilà il dit oui alors vous avez une
grande proportion philippa bêtifier à
ânonner à faire un peu le simplet oui et
ça que j'ai mis à côté d'eux parce qu'il
ya une mode en ce moment de la
crétinerie pas une mode flash compagnie
de mode la crétinerie nous nous sommes
des chrétiens hoebeke il ya philippe
katerine y avoue c'est un peu à la mode
de jouer les guinéens policiers dans la
mode
bassil remplaçants jouent pas au critère
est en retard mais c'est dans les chrs
et à son talent mais je préférais oui
j'ai donc pas d etat des gens qui ne
seraient pas crétin qui jouerait être
créé tant rêver vous allez faire et
comme c'est la mode des crétins d'état
peut-être mieux mais c'est très bien on
est ravi alors vous dites l'idée même de
l'intelligence au service de la chanson
me fait fuir
ouais ouais j'aime pas oui cette idée là
je pense tellement d'exemples ouais mais
bon je fais avec les moyens du bord
serge suis pas spécialement intelligent
intelligent donc je dis ça je fais faute
de mieux qua non mais l'addition vous
invitez c'est qu'on aime bien votre me
disent quand je comprends maintenant on
vous dit que c'est pas la peine de faire
d'être intelligent pour faire de bonnes
chansons c'est ça je crois non c'est pas
incompatible non plus mais
c'est pas nécessaire alors j'ai dit en
fait on est on est tous des robots en
fait il suffit de voir les gens
s'arrêter au feu rouge tout le monde
fait la même chose toute la journée quoi
oui oui on dit d'entrée on rentre on
deck sortiront ouais ça c'est vrai tu
fait qu'on nous dise un truc qu'on le
fait on est des robots de chair et de
sang mais des robots quand même quoi
basez pas incompatible - oui
puis on essaye d'être un robot j'ai fait
le disque des machines mais je me suis
aperçu qu'au fond ça n'avait pas du tout
kraft work ou quoi que ce soit c'est m
c'était plutôt l'humain qui revenait au
galop je me suis fait
et enfin d'ailleurs c'est ce que
j'attendais au final on est tous
conditionnés par les numéros oui enfin
conditionné je sais pas il ya des
histoires d'amour qui commence très vite
avec des numéros de donne moi ton temps
portable amber ouais c'est tout succès
des fois c'est le premier mot de
l'histoire d'amour et après ces deux
mois tenir au ta carte bleue
on peut être ses derniers
les chansons que j'aime bien c'est
l'album c'est celle qui est consacré 11
septembre
parce que c'est qu'est ce que tu fais le
11 septembre c'est en fait où tu étais
le sort de la coupe du monde c'est à
dire qu'en fait les gens c'est une façon
de se rassurer
parce que finalement ils ont une
histoire individuelle face aux grands
événements du monde quoi quand il ya des
avions qui s'écrasent dans les tours moi
je suis en train de manger un sandwich
sur un banc et pourtant ça se passe au
même moment tu t'en souviens tu dis le
11 septembre j'étais en train de manger
un sandwich sur un banc oui voilà sur en
même temps un sandwich à 310 facile
au port un map ali un panini soumont le
pire s'appelle bien ouais nan bien c'est
un peu une chanson tu est poursuivi par
marine le pen et tu dis que c'est une
histoire vraie oui ça s'est passé
comment ça s'est passé
à la maison de la radio doit être invité
à une autre émission politique ou pas
et puis c'est vrai je suis j'ai suivi
une fille blonde et s'est retournée
s'était tu fais un truc sur marine le
pen tu dis finalement c'est un être un
être humain quoi c'est ma soeur j'ai lu
ici pas supérieur même si je suis pas
d'accord avec ses opinions politiques
je me suis posé la question dans un
c'est vrai c'est ainsi il est invité à
un mariage où il ya marine le pen qui
est invité aussi sait-on jamais ça peut
arriver est proposée une partie de ping
pong qu'est ce que tu fais c'est sûr
c'est un être humain bien sûr ouais
après il faut gagner quoi que ça
l'important m
mais
[Musique]
voilà maintenant un truc c'est que tu
veux pas en fait tu te sentir supérieur
tu dis par exemple construit chante on
ou paul loup sulitzer tu dis après tout
qui vais pour critiquer pour
l'utilitaire quoi après tout c'est vrai
au fond c'est vrai et c'est vrai qu'elle
chantait marine le pen ces cétacés
enfin c'est pas un truc très de l'amour
a enregistré c'est pas des mots que tu
as envie de prononcer une chanson c'est
l'idée de faire une chanson vilaine au
fond avec des choses vilaine et qu'ils
peuvent
tu supporte pas quand calogero chante
tiananmen tu dis ça me donne des
frissons dans le dos quoi c'est pas
parce que le mec j'ai trouvé devant les
chars s'étaient pas lui quoi aura c'est
sûr et cela capable c'est pas prêt à
voir le document ouais je sais pas si
mais je sais pas pourquoi il fait ça
pour se faire passer pour ce mec je sais
pas mais mais
ça me déprime un peu moins bien parce
qu'il n'a pas donnés ce cri j'adore ou
alors ça fait un film aussi peau de
cochon c'est quoi alors à contenu alors
ce film c
c'est un film que j'ai fait tout seul
mais enfin c'est à dire je me suis
occupé de la lumière des des cornes
j'étais chef opérateur avec une petite
dv à ton rythme quoi c'est un film
extrêmement
laon qui peut s'accompagner
de haricots verts
le sac est chaud le conseil j'ai essayé
j'ai vu trois quatre fois ses films le
conseil avec du sac est chaud c'est
excellent
un samedi soir tu avais tout le monde en
parle
je crois que c'est une solution de repli
comment comment va aider la famille
helena noguerra comment va-t-elle très
bien viens de voir ici régulièrement il
a des sourds et quand elle me parle de
toi quand on te parle d'elle c'est la
moindre des choses c'est comme ludivine
sagnier
comment comment elle va alors très bien
juger j'ai dîné avec elle tout à l'heure
était en excellente état de forme est ce
qu est ce que l t'excite où elle te
dégoûte c'est très sûr à en juger par
évident fin
à faire l'interview stimulus la dentelle
par exemple la dentelle ça t'excite ou 7
des gouttes
ouais la dentelle
jean marine le pen en dentelle toujours
deux doses change pas une équipe qui
gagne
dentelles western ouais ouais tu
t'excites ou celle des gouttes
ça m'excite la dentelle c'est bien sûr
c'est que c'est ça tricote et ça me
dégoûte en même temps c'est excellent
mais sa mixité vrai dire aimer les
enfants une fille intelligente pas
enlevé une fille intelligente fille lila
dégoûte c'est excitant c'est bien
l'union
les talents aiguilles chat etc si tu
souhaites dégoûte les talons aiguilles
non ça me laisse complètement
indifférent ah oui oui c'est pas on n'a
pas lécher les talons aiguilles par
exemple bon laquelle une voiture
l'émission boîte les poignées d'amour
c'est sexy tous ept dégoûte
j'ai mené touché oui la télévision c'est
excite tous ept dégoûte ça m'excite pas
pas de seins padiet la non mais là c'est
toi qui nous excite à la moyenne des
gouttes à les odeurs corporelles sa
t'excite u7 dégoûte
ça m'excite excessivement oui et même à
lattes les odeurs de l'intérieur du
corps à et voilà
ça me fait penser au livre des ménages
ces éléments les tatouages cet ex itou 7
dégoûte
nicolas deschamps tu manges coup j'ai
embarqué tout de suite en arrivant soit
pas fini d colorier un brouillon
j'ai fait pas l'air mais je suis ni laid
ni colas ça fait que je suis très excité
celui-ci des fans tout nu ouais ouais
examen avec un bon sac et chaud entendre
tes voisins faire l'amour cet excellent
tout ça dégoûte un ça dépend si c'est en
dessous si ses voisins du sud soudan
dessus ouais séduit sont plus excitant
ça fait envie de grimper
voilà ce que je dis bien sûr un
transsexuel 7 excite tous ept dégoûte la
prochaine l'orissa t'excite ou 7 des
gouttes elle est quand même super week
end
[Musique]
lien en fermant les yeux j'aime
énormément c'est juste un super week-end
je tiens c'est excitant ça te dégoûte
tapotage simple et moi porter des sous
vêtements féminins ctq situe cette
dégoûte
et bien je le confesse ce soir oui ça
ticks oui c'est un hobby tu as quoi
kerry mois sur toi moi je suis jamais de
sous-vêtements de souvient laurent je
n'en porte pas tu devrais le savoir
depuis le toit j'ai zappé lio qui vient
dîner c'est t'excite 7 dégoûte
ça plombe un peu la soirée bon bah c'est
sûr ce sera une soirée pleine de vie de
deux d'entousiasme de parti pris dedans
volet nous ce sera forcément une bonne
soirée
vous allez paris bertrand cantat
sûrement assez ce premier sujet abordé
les poils partout 7 excite tous est déjà
les ihu toujours non voilà les poils
partout cette excitante des gundam
écrite mais c'est excitant à sucer un
orteil 7
c'est peut-être mon point faible vincent
delerm s'attaque si tout ça dégoûte
non je les aime beaucoup au fait qui va
te rends compte maintenant j'aime
énormément j'ai à chaque fois je le dis
je laime davantage gaza quand ça viendra
cette émission à 7 techcite ou 7 des
gouttes
bah là je vais juste bon j'avais une
fête une fête d'anniversaire
j'étais coupé un peu en plein vol entre
deux coupes de champagne savalas la
soirée suit son cours d'une façon plutôt
cohérente
[Musique]